hey guys Pete peppers here from candy
crush soda saga tips and I've had a
couple people ask me in the group or
Facebook group about this red hand here
the sticky hand booster
it's a switcher and I'll explain how it
works it's um it's not the most
devastating or you know it's it
literally just switches to pieces so it
doesn't have like an immediate crazy
effect but it could come in handy in
situations where you are trying to you
know I need to make a match and you
can't they have them in the original
candy crush and as far as I know there's
no difference in the way they work you
know here or there but uh I'm just
moving some pieces around and I mean
though you know if you can make a match
obviously like here you know I could
switch the orange on the yellow but you
don't need to so where would a place be
that we could use it effectively say
we're trying to get this this jelly
donut here there right a little bit of
the chocolate
taystee alright so here's an example
it's not the best example but it will
show you say say we wanted to make
instead of matching the color bomb with
the fish we want to cut we wanted to
match it with the striped so we would
take our handout click on the fish and
then we can switch them back and forth
see that so now we can make a a striped
candy color bomb combo instead of the
fish and you know that's really all
there is to it um that would be a pretty
good example as you can see I cleared
out a lot more chocolate than I would
have with the fish and other situations
might be like if you're trying to get to
you know a bear on the frosting level or
honey level you know you need to get
into the spot you know you could use it
to switch things around so I hope that
at least clears it up how it works
it's it's not new like I said it's from
the other game but it's um it's new and
so todo so if you didn't know how it
works I hope this helped you figure it
out please like the video if you found
it helpful and subscribe to my channel
so you can get more videos like this as
soon as they're released thanks